the horns are cool yeah but they're done
look at horrible hi and we are
professionals from the tattoo industry
and we're gonna be reviewing tattoos
from in movies here we go
Harry Potter Harry Potter I definitely
thought that this was a kids movie badly
done tattoo horrible yeah not a good
tattoo at all great movie splotchy and
blurry the skulls snake thing pooping we
have a shot from Eastern Promises all I
can say is scary yeah he looks jacked up
yeah you could tell that he's been to
prison those in a shop for sure if I saw
a dude walking down the street with
Russian tattoos like that I would avoid
him dude where's my car
yes Jose ever I don't care about the
quality of them it was one of the
greatest tattoo scenes in the movie I
actually don't think these tenses are
that bad honestly this is probably like
something you would get for your first
tattoo and they're laughing at each
other oh I like this tattoo this is from
strangers I'm sitting right there
tattoos not bad very well done it's a
yes Pirates of the Caribbean Caribbean
urban yeah your tattoos need to be big
enough so that your detail doesn't
splash up like that the tattoo looks
like your typical like 1950s old-school
yeah got to Sun beating this mint oh
yeah come on dude I think one of the
Backstreet Boys he's like I got tattoos
finally get a pack of Hostess the
lettering is really off like that should
have happened that's really bad
I would hate a client that came in and
was like can we put the letter in
backwards so I can read it in the mirror
ah
Black Swan tattoo on the back yeah those
are caller willies that's impressive
that you knew what those were everybody
knows what they are no one knew what
they were not done well no no contrast
at all whoa
that's me Moana they look pretty cool
yeah I like them I think that they are
composed really well on the piece people
come in all the time asking for this
stuff seems not realizing that there is
a meaning by
everything I never seen this movie don't
come in and say that you want something
like this and tell us it's gonna take
two hours okay try like twelve woods
it's supposed to be like robotic wings
out of tribal oh god that looks like
barbed wire yeah Suicide Squad The Joker
Joker's joking letters and the hahaha up
top is good red dragon this looks like a
horribly done garage tattoo yeah I just
don't like the shading it's just like
it's like the guy was rushing to finish
this that's it
[Applause]
[Music]